bonjour je suis isabelle giacchino et ma
recherche a porté sur les émissions de
variétés de maritie et gilbert
carpentier
ce nom vous évoque sans doute quelque
chose laissez moi deviner des paillettes
des duos des danseurs en cascade sacha
distel en playback
c'est à peu près ça mais pas seulement
le couple carpentier a produit en une
trentaine d'années pas moins de 500
émissions regardées à l'époque par des
millions de téléspectateurs
[Musique]
ma problématique est donc simple comment
expliquer ce succès télévisuel et une
carrière d'une telle longévité
pour répondre à ces questions j'ai
consulté sur ce très variés à
l'inathèque j'ai croisé l'analyse des
émissions avec des dossiers décrivant la
conception des décors des dossiers de
production ou bien même des articles de
presse
en rattachant toujours mon propos aux
évolutions des cadres techniques et
institutionnelles à la télévision
française
je me suis rapidement aperçu que la
carie carpentier était très
représentative de la trajectoire des
premiers producteurs de télévision comme
beaucoup les carpentier commence à
travailler pour des radios privées et
selon sts à la télévision au début des
années 60
[Musique]
à cette période le producteur n'est pas
du tout le corps professionnel puissant
qu'il est aujourd'hui
les carpentier produite en effet leur
première émission de télévision dans un
studio complètement vétuste
dix ans plus tard ils se retrouvent dans
le plus grand et le plus beau studio de
loire tf le sud 17 construit
spécialement pour eux ils sont à leur
programme et de manière hebdomadaire et
apparaissent aux yeux de tous comme les
rois des variétés à la façon de tuer
à la façon que tu
hatem entendre un petit fils heures
soit j'ai expliqué comment la formule et
carpentier apporter des états unis est
adapté de manière originale fut l'une
des clés de ce succès l'idée est très
simple chaque émission est créé sur
mesure pour un artiste qui la présente
lui-même chante des duos avec d'autres
vedettes et se prêtent à des mises en
scènes variées
le tout est présenté sur un ton léger et
onirique dans des décors fastueux le
bureau des vols
oui mais cette
[Musique]
les carpentier sont portés par ailleurs
par un contexte favorable études
d'opinion course vers le divertissement
la télévision des années 70 se fait de
plus en plus récréative
ils tirent leur révérence au cours des
années 80 au moment même où leur métier
évolue sensiblement et où de nombreuses
sociétés de production privée voit le
jour ils laissent dans leur sillage de
grands moments de télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]